as I feel like when you when we met on
set you I think it was at the beginning
and we were doing all the dry stuff and
I was bragging about how I've never been
dryer it off yes totally right yes and I
think I might have even in a moment of
brilliant intuition said come check back
in with me at the end and boy didn't
change I was like I can't believe I said
that at one point it was just right but
I mean I would expect when you are
making a movie called Aquaman it's not
gonna be a dry shoot yes you would have
been right in that I mean I
instinctually want to say yeah I
wouldn't I understand why you would have
intuitively thought that I did too I
expected that and that's why I made that
comment to you when we met on set about
how dry I'm this amazing and then
foot-in-mouth it was like right after
that is when it all changed and then we
started filming all the scenes basically
from that point on I was soaked every
day we shot all the scenes where we were
under the water dry and so those were
just a very limited amount of scenes at
the beginning of the shoot all the other
scenes involved us being soaking wet so
yeah and you got pneumonia on what day
just I think he opposed a co-working
pneumonia I just dealt with it
throughout one of the things about the
previous DC movies is that they've been
a little darker and this is more first
of all that I really enjoyed the movie
and it's like bright and fun and it's
really different than what's come before
can you sort of talk about that I you
know I don't I'm not going to compare it
to anything because it really feels like
its own movie I I just don't know how
James Wan did it this movie checks all
the boxes it is it's comedy
it's got love and romance
you know that's building it's kind of
like an action romance but adventure and
then it's it's got hazel you know
James's classic horror elements are in
there I mean it really does have
something for everyone it really it
really it really does check all the
boxes completely one of the things about
this I really appreciate that it's just
an aqua
movie and there's no other DC characters
saying that if you could have been like
had a cameo of another DC character who
would you have liked to have seen well I
mean I'm a DC character no but you know
what I mean like you guys are it's like
your movie do you know what I mean like
it's not you don't see like Blue Beetle
or like Lobo or some of these other
people you know in the background yeah
well that's part of why I really liked
this is that we get to be a part of an
origin story we got to create a world
and be a part of a world that we've
never seen before it's visually stunning
and exciting and you get to go on this
adventure for the first time with the
audience you've never we've never seen
Atlantis we've never gotten to know
Aquaman and this is really the story
about how Arthur curry became Aquaman
and how in the process you get to meet
Mara and you and she really becomes who
were at a later understand mera is but
we got to introduce these characters I
really liked that they were on their own
you